[Music]
[Applause]
bill orms had an interesting last couple
of days he covers the lakers for the
athletic and bill kind enough to join us
how would you describe the last couple
of days there bill
oh very low-key dan just very uh
very low-key uh it does turn out that
when lebron james uh uh
says something about you or tweets about
you other people want to say things
about you and tweet about you so i've
had a lot of i've had a lot of that over
the last few days but otherwise pretty
good 80 degrees in los angeles yesterday
okay but uh tell the audience what you
reported and why lebron james reacted to
that or how he did
well so i mean obviously after his
comments uh at all-star weekend about
potentially returning to cleveland and
his various um praise for
other executives on the heels of the
lakers not making a move at the trade
deadline
there was a lot of
um tea leave reading and a lot of
interpretation and we're talking about
lebron james who's one of the master
uh
master tweakers in the history of of you
know uh the organizations he works for
and
um sub tweets and sort of you know
trying to push buttons kind of behind
the scenes and so um you know i reported
you know several things kind of reported
uh related to lebron including you know
that
the subtext is that within the lakers
organization and sort of
sort of um
along with the trend of the rest of the
nba and lebron helped usher this in he
has more power within the lakers
organization than any player ever has
and that includes kobe bryant and um
and so what i you know basically wrote
was that lebron
was using that platform in that moment
to sort of apply pressure to the lakers
to get what he wanted from the lakers
whatever that might be whatever his
vision whether it's a contract extension
whether it's just to kind of hold the
lakers feet to the fire a little bit
more and remind them that he could
potentially leave if things don't go his
way um
and then in the aftermath of that of
course lebron uh you know
basically wrote that no one should
listen to me i guess but um
but
but um you know we talked about it we're
good
but how was that so he pulls you aside
and just wants to have a
heart-to-heart man-to-man conversation
uh i just say i would just say we talked
about in the hallway i hit his press
conference and we had a conversation
about it and you know i had a couple
thoughts on it and he had a couple
thoughts on it and then you know it
seems like we landed in a pretty good
place
because it doesn't take
you know that much time to connect the
dots here of what he's saying how he's
saying it and then all of a sudden hey
um you guys didn't do anything at the
trade deadline is it well let me ask you
that it almost felt like the lakers said
look lebron this is what you wanted you
deal with it you you wanted anthony
davis we gave up all those young players
we gave up picks you wanted russell
westbrook we wanted buddy healed you got
it go you know make the best of it is
that is that
yeah i think that's absolutely you know
a reasonable assessment and also any
change they were going to make even if
it was the um
even if it was the john the john wall
trade right which made a lot of sense
john wall is also a client of clutch
sports which you know is clutches lebron
lebron is clutch rich paul uh runs
clutch sports um that would have needed
that would that that's a move that would
have disadvantaged the lakers right they
would have had to give up that first
round pick in 2027 or even a
pick swap in 2027 which you know is you
know we don't know where the lakers are
going to be five years from now that
could end up being a really catastrophic
pick swap and so while you are in win
now mode i think there was also a real
healthy dose of reality from the lakers
to say you know we can be in win now
mode all we want we can't win now so
there is a little bit of get to the off
season get to you know make the best of
this season maybe something breaks your
way and you you know
maybe you could win a playoff series if
something really breaks your way but um
get to the postseason and then and then
kind of lick your wounds and reassemble
them
do you think lebron ends his career as a
laker
i would say yes i think i think that you
know i think that there was the you know
some saber rattling over the all-star
weekend i don't think lebron wants to go
anywhere i don't think it makes sense
for him to go anywhere i don't know that
if he were to leave at age 38 39 he's
going to find another organization that
is willing to give him the same sort of
equity you know not not obviously actual
ownership but ownership of of you know
action that the the lakers have unless
it is a scenario where he is you know
going somewhere where he is literally
going to become a part of the ownership
group upon retiring or something like
that but i do think there is a real
strong chance i'd probably put it like
60 40 right i tipped to him him
finishing his career with the lakers um
you know the brawny element is
fascinating but i still think it makes
the most sense for you know
this to sort of funnel brawny to the
lakers at some point for a year or two
and it because again
i don't know
how many teams like i think you'd have
to be a team without a real direction or
plan to say
well our best path forward is to
draft a you know draft ronnie james you
know assuming he's a draftable player um
but not knowing really where he's going
to be at that stage you know how how
much like a foundational type player he
could be and then to get a 40 year old
lebron like if that's your best path
forward um then you really probably are
at total rock bottom as an nba franchise
that sounds like something the knicks
would do bill
like i said you'd have to be a total
rock bottom as an nba franchise
yeah i don't even know if brawny can
play at that level i i've watched high
school games hell i look good in high
school bill so i i don't know
if i'm a team do you call lebron's bluff
and you draft brony a lot higher
than he would probably normally have
gone
i mean i think that's the thing that
people
i mean we're still talking about lebron
two years from now and we've been
while lebron is still putting up massive
numbers you know he's averaging you know
you know he's averaging mvp caliber
numbers um he's had way more injuries
than he's had in his career he has he's
started to look his age a little bit
more even if you watched the other night
uh in the lost in new orleans he didn't
seem to have the same burst and he'd
mentioned you know kind of acknowledged
that he you know didn't look great even
though he had 32 points i think that
knees bothering him so this year he's
had the knee he's had he's had an ab
strain he's had an ankle injury
last year he had the bad ankle injury so
these things are starting to add up so
who's even gonna know who even knows
where lebron's gonna be in two years and
whether a team is going to
see that two-for-one deal as the you
know as the
as the you know as the steel that we
might think of it now
how are the clippers by the way
uh they're i mean they're they're fun
right i mean we saw them last week
against the lakers and again against uh
we'll see them again this week that's
that's a really fascinating team because
they kind of like before they got kawhi
and paul george they have such a strong
identity it sort of transcends their
stars um and then you can bring those
stars in you know so if kawhi pg
norman powell if there's a scenario
those guys got back for a play in for
the postseason it would be a really like
you know unbelievable development and it
would it would really add some spice to
the postseason
how would you uh rate steph curry's
all-star performance
i mean just all time i mean
just all the time
i don't know what against what
benchmark to you know judge things
happening in an all-star game like you
know he could make 33s in an all-star
game and i don't know that i would be
like that bowled over but
to see him just go out and have
that kind of performance you know
knock down all those threes the joy that
he brings to the game watching everybody
else kind of embrace him um you know he
is
you know we get very caught up in lebron
and you know kevin durant
but steph curry has you know really
dominated this decade and to have kind
of that sort of signature performance on
an exhibition stage i think it's just
like one of those other feathers in the
cap of a hall of fame career and i've
said this before i don't know if you
agree but i'll bring it up that you know
michael had such an impact in fact the
nba is still trying to kind of get out
from his shadow there but what steph
curry has done
he's done more for more basketball
players than i think michael's style
michael entertained us but we couldn't
do that
we feel like we can do what steph curry
does
and i think he'll have a greater impact
on the game uh actual playing than than
michael will what do you think it's
funny we had a conversation in
an interview setting with malik monk a
few weeks ago and it was we're asking
malik monk who has had a great year for
the lakers whether he
um was disappointed he wasn't in the
slam dunk contest and he said
no like i'm the more disappointed i
wasn't in the three-point contest it's
like why why the slam dunk contest is so
much cooler and he was like and
our point was because anybody can shoot
a three-pointer and he's like not like
me
and i think that that is i think that is
i think that is the kind of the same
idea where steph curry took this thing
that felt very relatable and that
anybody could like go out on the court
and do and you could sort of feel like
steph if you knocked one down and he's
made it feel cooler than dunking he's
made it feel as unreachable as you know
jumping you know higher than you could
jump because he does it at such an
unbelievable
at such an unbelievable level and the
video that was going around from
pre-game the other day where he made 13
straight shots he did his whole shooting
routine from every distance you know
moving all the way back up to half court
and then all the way back into the paint
um was you know just
i i do think we take for granted like
that he has actually perfected the most
fundamental skill of basketball
and maybe john marant will bring back
the dunk because
you know for a smaller guy
he attacks the hoop like derrick rose
did when he first came into the nba and
everybody wants to shoot threes
jaws bringing it every night he's
bringing it to anybody everybody
well and like people will always love a
small guy who can dunk
and like i mean to see jaw at his size
you know fly through the air and like
you said anybody over over great shot
blockers the less the best shot black
blockers in the league he is um you know
completely
i mean dunking i think at a certain
point got kind of passe right you watch
the dung contest they're kind of out of
moves to do they're you only go between
your legs so many times behind your back
off the balance off the backboard off
the side of the backboard you've seen it
all but we haven't really seen a guy i
mean even d rose didn't like really
didn't like put it down on guys like
we've seen john do over over these
couple years he's been in the league i
mean he is to me one of the the three or
four guys in the nba i would actually i
would pay my own money to like go sit in
like the nosebleeds just to watch play
basketball who are the others
can i have five yeah sure
lebron steph oh are you saying lebron
just because you got to be nice to him
now
no lebron james is still worth the price
of admission come on
very much the worth of with the price of
that okay all right you're kissing
kd and
giannis jokic
both both are in there okay
all right that's six
yeah i like i i people are talking about
demar derozan i said when's the last
time an mvp candidate didn't have a
highlight that you remembered
and demar derozan doesn't have any
highlight he doesn't make the highlights
it's just you look at the box score and
you go and he scored 30 again
um
jokic it feels like his passing stands
out more than anything else john moran
is going to have signature plays here uh
the greek freak has signature play i
don't know how much that factors in
you know with mvp voters of
the style the the you know being a
performer um
that goes along with how valuable you
are to your team
i think it i think it helps just in the
sense of having you know you know
something in your mind's eye right like
the kind of that signature moment or
that defining
sort of
characteristic or trait i mean demar
derozan's game has never been flashy or
that highlight worthy it's it's always
been sort of you know it's been
accumulation like oh man he knocked down
nine nine mid-range jumpers or he
finally shot some threes you know
whatever he does um has never been
flashy and what it's been to me has been
the accumulation and the consistency
with that bulls team the bulls obviously
being atop the west excuse me the east
and having you know really come out of
nowhere i mean i don't think anybody saw
them as
uh as as a contender or having a good
offseason but it felt like you know you
overpay for damar you know who knows
about lonzo and caruso and those
everything they did has has hit and so
demar is in the conversation not only
because he's individually playing like
an mvp but because he's elevated his
team but you're right in the sense that
not i don't think highlights win mvps
but i do think having sort of
memorable
memorable moments and memorable games to
sort of to sort of
stick in voters minds does matter but i
almost feel like demar's numbers and the
fact that he kind of did has come out of
nowhere this season i mean always a very
good player every year borderline
all-star but then now be putting up the
numbers that he's putting up to me
that is almost a highlight the highlight
is the fact you can't you can't
disregard him you don't forget him
because it's been so unexpected for him
this year yeah it's almost like an
overnight sensation that took 10 years
in the making with uh demar derozan uh
play nice this week bill okay
that's right all right thanks for
joining us
thank you bill orm the lakers writer for
the athletic you imagine you write this
and then all of a sudden you had some
people who were upset with bill orem and
then lebron says uh hey come here
lebron wants to talk to you and you know
while he said hey i wasn't the source of
this story and you know that somebody
was and sources run the game and all of
those things
but you know this is what you do when
when you get
stared down by somebody and it's
happened to me before when you report
something
uh lawrence taylor i thought was
gonna punch me uh when i
was covering him when he uh had to have
a press conference talking about being
suspended cocaine news